what legally can be done at this point
for mr pinner and mr aslan remembering
of course that the area where they've
been tried and convicted is not
recognized by any other country other
than russia
well
liga good morning
legally there's not that much that can
be done
you're talking about a
court which is not independent which is
not regularly constituted
which
answers no doubt directly to putin so
international law
national law does not really account for
such courts
in terms of being able to intervene
if putin was listening to international
law then we could go to the european
court of human rights but if putin was
listening to international law this
wouldn't have happened in the first
place
absolutely right and mr jordan i wonder
if you're clear at all in the sort of
the legal community what who are these
people that was that sentenced them the
judge that was involved in this do we
know who these people are and what kind
of legal standing they have
well all we know is that they are
officials or authorities of their
breakaway
um
uh donetsk people's republic
which is a separatist movement which is
controlled by putin and the kremlin so
we know that they are acting at the
behest of the kremlin we know that
they've acted at the behest of the
kremlin since 2014.
these men were arrested or detained or
surrendered i should say in mario paul
at a time when russia was attacking
maripo so they were transferred to this
area in donetsk
at the behest of russia at the behest of
the kremlin and um this is a
tactic clearly
to place them into the uh separatist
area
and distance themselves to an extent
from the kremlin but it's it's a
transparent attempt they are officials
of this breakaway republic which have
throughout as i say from 2014 answered
directly to the kremlin
and you say it's a transparent attempt i
mean
so in your mind it's quite clear what's
happening here are these guys going to
be used eventually do you think as pawns
to try and get some kind of prisoner
swap some kind of concession from
ukraine in the west
well no doubt about it i mean the stat
the starting point is that they were
they they surrendered in mario paul the
world watched as mario paul was attacked
by
russia and the ukrainians defended the
ukrainian military defended so it's
crystal clear that these men were part
of the ukrainian armed forces as such
they're entitled to combat immunity they
can't just be prosecuted
except if they are suspected of
violating international humanitarian law
that's not the challenges here the
charges are that they acted as
mercenaries that they are involved in
terrorism and so on and so forth
so it's it's crystal clear um that there
is this strategy and it's crystal clear
that um
it's a strategy to achieve something and
i i've got i think there's no doubt that
the the something
is to squeeze concessions out of the
international community
likely to be uh squeezing uh or making
it more difficult for the british the uk
government to intervene and support
ukraine's military something which putin
and
lavrov and the other kremlin
stooges have been
talking about for some time warning the
west that if they kept intervening
there'd be consequences and this is
likely one of the consequences yeah and
of course hanging over this is that
threat of death by firing squad i mean i
i've had a i think this morning and i
wonder if you can help there is no legal
press there is no precedent legal
there's no precedent to this is there as
to where we are with the situation with
these two men who've been captured
foreign men captured in a war zone who
are now threatened with the death
penalty in recent times
well certainly there's no precedent um
in since 2014 when russia first invaded
ukraine um i think
russia has certainly ramped up the
the pressure uh and and of course it
needs more concessions this is the first
time the west has really got engaged and
uh to support ukraine in a meaningful
way militarily so it's certainly
unprecedented um within uh ukraine and
russia since 2014
and it's probably i can't think off the
top my head of recent examples globally
actually it's quite unusual but then
you know putin's invasion is quite
unusual his speech is about um
conquering land
um and ukraine being a colony and uh not
sovereign
these are also unprecedented so we are
unfortunately in unprecedented times